this is boring
um
i mean on the actual slide but i'm
actually running it in firefox
and that's not cool you know the saying
that um
vim is a great editor it's just it just
lacks a good operating system
well the thing is i actually have emacs
and amex is a proper
operating system these days so i'm going
to try something new i'm going to try
actually just running my slides from
emacs
so these are reveal js lights
and i shall warn you this this thing is
extremely unstable
it it actually just crashes randomly
at some points so um
if this goes boom when that's part of
the excitement
let's see emacs
where is it going now vamisa
right so um
so i figured um since my language isn't
really uh quite as clever or as finished
as
uh as the previous languages i i just do
a talk on essentially how i built it
so the idea is i'm going to try to show
you um
how to build your own lisp which is kind
of a right of a traditional rite of
passage for most developers
in fact if you look at github um well
actually if you look at github
github's most uh frequently repeated
projects you're probably going to find
something like
um async control flow libraries for note
but then
list toy lisps are probably going to be
number two
ish so uh
why would anyone want to do that wait
unless focus
emacs please work
so why would anyone want to do that
well first of all because he can but
um from a more personal perspective um
i have this idea about the perfect
language
and the perfect language is closure
bear with me please closure is is
for a start it's a lisp and lisp lisps
are just
i mean we have like a 50 year tradition
of this
lists being beautiful elegant languages
it's extremely powerful and i mean it
gives you
unprecedented meta programming powers
and closure
in particular is um
i'm looking at rich i'm i'm trying not
to to
yeah it is just
so perfectly designed that you i mean
even though it lacks the type system you
can't really go wrong with closure
so the perfect language is haskell
haskell what closure aspires to
to function in purity haskell is
actually
completely uncompromising about that and
it has an extremely powerful type system
so powerful
that as long as your haskell program
compiles you can be pretty sure that
it is bug free it doesn't mean that
you've got the program that you
thought you were writing but it's going
to be
um a correct program at least
so haskell just fills me with with
thoughts of warm fussy things which have
got monads in haskell
now the problem is that we we have a bit
of a logical dilemma here because both
closure and haskell are in fact the
perfect language
so i figured that the actual perfect
language
um would be something that kind of
combines the two
and well thanks to michael fergus has
been
off quoted here today let's go in a
language called
shen which had me extremely excited
it's got s expressions and macros and
all the
programming parts that you would expect
from a lisp it's got pattern matching
which which um haskell
gives us just uh
by far one one of my favorite control
structures
it's got a very advanced type system
it's it's in fact a lisp
with a proper type system
and it's even got a logic engine would
you believe that it's got this kind of
prologue thing embedded inside it so
this has got to be the perfect language
so i started having a look at it
and i found that it has a
cumbersome syntax when you want to to be
a bit more complicated about your type
systems
it's got a strange license that a lot of
people are complaining about
now i i could deal with those things i
mean
syntax is just syntax right and licenses
we can just pretend they didn't exist
i think but the worst thing is it it's
actually got mutable data structures
and yeah
you you just don't do that
so sadly that just turned me completely
off shen i mean it's it's
to be fair it's definitely a brilliant
language but it has these things that
just
don't click with me so
what what is one to do well obviously
you write your own language
so um
i just sat down one weekend started
writing a language
it's pure like haskell
it's immutable obviously like both
closure and haskell
and all languages should be it's home
iconic
it's it's um more or less a lisp at
least
it's tight or at least it's going to be
when i finish the type system
i discovered that writing lisps is quite
easy
and quite quick but writing type systems
that's a whole different story
so i i rate our ho poodle um
in the status in about right now um
in april and since then i've been
working and just trying to figure out
what to do with the time system
i i wrote the actual buddha in in about
a weekend
and i've been using with three or four
months since then to just
get my head wrapped around type systems
types are hard
and the best part of beidon is that
it actually uses unicode characters in
the syntax
and um bowdoin
had its time on the the hackiness front
page
and most commenters decided in that
because it actually used uh
characters outside the the ascii
characters that that was extremely
irresponsible and
it was bound to fail
so that was quite reassuring
so this is what puerto actually looks
like um you'll notice the the unico
characters there
we've got the florian um which is is
essentially them
defining a named function you've got the
arrow there the right arrow because
aries are beautiful
um it also saves your character
compared to to languages like airline
which used
the minus and the was that greater than
to simulate aries but hey this is 2013
right we can use unicode now so
um you notice that um it's got pattern
matching
much like haskell and apart from that it
looks
quite a lot like a lisp this
this is a functional hello world the the
factorial function
um i could have done regular hello and
except that burnham doesn't actually
have i o yet
so it can get fancy
with a pattern matching um this is this
is an implementation of a map function
a bit naive perhaps but it works it
takes a function and a list
and if the list is empty then it just
returns an empty list
and you'll notice the the kind of um
destructuring of the the dossier
notation then
pretty much exactly like haskell to
iterate over
a list um so you get the the heads
um and the dots and the rest of the list
essentially
so this is quite traditional let's just
see if we can get this to run
because this is c-max right this is the
this is the good part
so um i'm just going to fire an
imperialist buffer
that was of course
of course that couldn't work that would
have been too easy
so why is it actually
wait a minute let's try that again still
doesn't work and i have no idea why it's
trying to run landing and instead of
actually build on
never mind so you're just going to have
to take my word for it that these
functions actually work
it doesn't really matter
so how do you actually uh
build a lisp
this still comes with my little pudding
background so i'm being consistent here
well first of all you're gonna have to
pick a language to implement
it in and you're generally free to to
pick any language you like as long as
it's closure
you'll see why in a bit well actually um
what i discovered
while building budo is that it really
helps
to to to cheat in the initial phase of
development
uh if you're actually writing your list
in another lisp
for one thing i used closure as a parser
for the longest time
and that really brings me to to
the first topic of the day passing
um that's really why you have to start
with with any language
and this is thing uh for closure called
interpos
written by by mark englebank which is um
intended to be kind of um a universal
passer
the i think his idea is to try and make
passing as
ubiquitous as regular expressions
it's um it's a fairly efficiency at el
paso
and it uses just
essentially a plain eb and f syntax
that's extended back a snore form
and of course if you're done in
speedwack you could use posit
combinators instead it's a very flexible
library
but we're going to stick with where the
back is now
oops i'm going different so
i have some code for you
if i can find it i think i'm actually in
the wrong project yes i am
so presenting from emacs is actually
hard would you believe it
here's my project
here's my instaparse so i'm going to see
if i can get
um yes an unwrapped buffer
so i'm going to compile this i'm going
to go here and i'm going to give you an
example of instapass
so i'm going to define a person i'm
going to use
insta pass to define it
and so i'm gonna just
um write a very simple process for a
very
stupid toy language for you first of all
we need some
white space and it
you can use regular expressions to
define this
so this is going to match just a bit of
a white space and i want numbers
and numbers are of course defined like
this
using regular expressions
and so i'm going to make an expression
room which can be
let's say a number at first see if we
can do something about this wrong number
of arguments
really
[Music]
right so this should let us
call a p insta slash pulsar is a
function that will return a positive
function
which i can just call and so if i
provide a number
let's go bigger you'll see that we get
some kind of
a syntax tree the expression
matches the expression rule and it
contains the number when the value of 30
and 30 stomach
now usually we don't want to see the
number thing here
on this base for that matter
so
let's we we use them
the angle brackets is that we call them
um
we use those to to to tell inspires that
we didn't care about this part
so we get a clean syntax tree
in fact let's just you know hide the
loss of it
so that's the syntax tree for just
a number let's just um
we're going to add some some s
expressions right
so parentheses are nice
and we need something to put in there
first of all we don't care about the
parentheses so we hide them
but we need some kind of syntax for some
kind of operation
let's do add
and it's going to be a space and a
number
and a space and another number
and so this could
be an ad room
so we can do add 1337.
how come that doesn't work
oh sorry yes of course thank you
so now it passes now we see that we
don't care about the worst pace at all
we're just gonna hide that
so that's a simple apostrophe that gives
you at least an idea
about how insta pass works now
let us see if we can find a bit more
of an advanced person for you so this is
perel's um
[Music]
parser you see it's it's not very big i
mean it's definitely more complicated
than what we just did
but this being something like a lisp
it's it's got a very simple syntax
so we've got about
a page full of rules page and a half
um it's a little more complicated than a
regular list because i
decided that uh functions are actually
going to be uh
syntax and not just lists as in regular
lisps um
but there you go um it essentially works
the same way let's see if we can make
that run
so where did my wrapper go there we are
so
much the same thing with the final
parser
and let's do some viral code um
let's do a lambda it takes a number n
and returns an incremental n
so that essentially gives us um the ast
for for a burnout program
so that is extremely uncomplicated you
can do this now right
you can just go home and at least write
a parser so let's take that further
when my slides go
there we go so another thing you need
is primitive types
by that i do not mean types in the type
system sense obviously i mean
runtime types like strings numbers
booleans
symbols this being a lisp it's got to
have um
we'll be right to go in the first class
symbols let's go than that
and this is isn't strictly a primitive
type
but it's kind of important because our
code
is built out of consensus
in this case of course are immutable
apart from that
that the traditional concern we don't
care about
um creating extremely efficient uh data
structures at this point we just want to
get the language working
so we're going to try constance so
i am going to
show you i'm still oh right
let me see he makes it complicated
don't tell him any money
types
so quite simply um
i define the basic data types as
implementations
of a protocol called l-type
which simply provides the interface for
getting a value out of it
and i got some fancy macro stuff going
up going on up here
so i create booleans number strings and
symbols they're very easy
they only essentially contain values
and i got the console down here
implements much of the same
interfaces but it's a lot more
complicated um
so compile switch namespace i can do
things like um
creating a number this is what um a
number representation in
in inside the runtime looks like
and
same thing etc
i can do consing
so that's the dotted form and i can also
of course um
i can also of course keep counting them
together to create
lists there's a list with two numbers
so um this is going to be your your
basic building blocks
you actually want the passat to um
let's see wait
i'm gonna do this right you actually
kind of want
wait uh
pass that let's say like this if you're
going to be difficult
you you kind of want to transform the
the thing that comes out of interpass
in surpass into your data types
so i got something to do that i got some
code up here i could
just reuse i guess so i got a function
called pass
which instead of um
of the ast and actually outputs um data
types
this being a function
so once you've got that sorted you can
start
building the actual language runtime
so you're going to have to start with
evaluation
and essentially your eval function is
going to take a program and an
environment in and it's going to output
a result of the evaluation and it's
going to put a potentially changed
environment
so um incidentally what does this look
like to you
um what would be a great way to
implement
these two steps
moon ads you should know this
actually this is this is almost exactly
what
what a statement does um
you get you have a function that creates
a function that takes some state and
performs a set operation
and returns a result and some new state
also murders are awesome so you kind of
have to use them
um i keep doing this sorry
uh no not
so the idea here is
that you can have let's say
we want an operation that defines
a symbol in the scope
so we take a symbol and a value
and we return a function which takes
some state
let's call that the environment it's
really ways
and it returns a list that contains a
result
and i think for this example we're going
to make the result just
nothing and it takes a changed
environment
so we have the option of because the
environment is being passed in we have
the option of changing it
um actually returning a changed
environment not mutating the
the actual environment obviously so
we just add um we suppose the
environment is just a map
and we add the symbol and its value to
the map
so
if we call that
let's say we do keyword foo
1300 so that returns a function
let's call that function with some
initial state let's just use an empty
map
and you see that we get a result back
the one that we specified
and we get a new environment
with the value set
so this is a basic statement
let's add some one actually
performs a calculation one that just
adds two numbers together
same format this is just basic statement
and stuff
but here we actually return a result
which is nil
we perform the calculation
get an a so the idea is that we pass
two symbols in the ad operation is gonna
resolve the symbols from the environment
and
it's going to return the result of
adding them together
we're going to assume that the numbers
and we are not going to change the
environment for this operation so we
just return it
as this so
let's create a program
now i got someone at helper functions um
that generally runs through on a beta
reduce state this takes some initial
state and it takes a series of
statements or monarch values
and runs them as a program in sequence
and i'm passing the new state along as
it goes
and it finally returns the result of the
final operation
so there should be a list we can add
food to the environment
we can add bar to the environment i
think you see
where i'm going with this
so what's this gonna do
so this essentially um this
does some kind of a reduction
on this list of magnetic values and
essentially what it does is it evaluates
the program
and it totally doesn't work i just
realized
i forgot something didn't i
why didn't you guys put this you're very
bad developers
see now answer together
and you'll notice that we have added um
both to the scope and
at the end we get we do the add
and that is the result right there
so that's how to do program evaluation
using statements
and the great thing about that of course
is when you're writing a language that's
supposed to be pure
it's kind of important um at least for
you for a hipster crap
that your implementation is also
equally pure so burnout is is
insistently
uh using statements instead of any kind
of mutable state because mutable state
is unnatural as we know
so next slide
so this this thing called scoping
and we want lexical scoping which means
that our functions are out of scope is
occurred around it
not where it's invoked from that would
be dynamic scoping and that is stupid
i mean what are we emacs lisp so
that brings me to functions by the way
i'm not going to
go too deeply into this
but i am representing a function in
bordeaux
as its own data type um
so and it's essentially the same as as
my primitive data types it uses the same
protocols except
it's a bit more complicated and you
notice
that when i create the lambda value
i pass it a scope when i create the
value
instead of when i invoke it that's what
makes
the difference between lexical and
dynamic scoping
um i created um
a toy list earlier where i actually made
this mistake
figure that when you when you want to
call a function
you just pass the current state to the
function and the function does whatever
to the state and you return that
and that doesn't read well dynamic
scoping
um means that it's it's
it's hard to see where your scope comes
from
and so it's harder to reason about it
this is why lexical scoping is good and
i'm very glad that emacs list was
actually
um giving you the option now of doing
both i hope that there
they will eventually get rid of a
dynamic scripting because it's stupid i
mean even javascript gets
this right so
what kind of right at least you still
have how to deal with that
then the function versus block scope
thing but that's another story
another language so
evaling a function
um when when you're you're evaluating
a number it's it's quite easy because
the result of evaluating a number is the
number
and same with the strings and booleans
functions there actually do things
so yeah you can see there's a lot of
code here
it's complicated by the fact of pattern
matching but never mind
so
yeah what can i say about this
so when i evaluate the actual lambda
which is
which is represented in the syntax tree
you'll notice that i bind the current
scope to it
this is kind of compile time you can say
this is what gives us lexical scoping i
mind the scope
when the lambda value is being defined
and when i invoke it
and this being a lisp i
still evaluates constants where the
lambda
is is
wait this is wrong so um
a lambda is still represented by a list
in theory
which allows hopefully later macros
so you have to deal with evaluating that
and i'm
going to deeply into this so let's get
back to the slides
pattern mashing i mentioned pattern
matching
and of course um the smart thing at this
point will be to actually
read luke mara and jay's paper which
which describes how to create a very
efficient
machine for doing pattern matching and
closure's core match library actually
uses this to get effect however we are
lazy
so we are going to use chord logic
instead we're just going to run star
match it
because it's so much easier
so let's do some core logic
david nolan couldn't make it strangely
so i'm going to have to try and fill in
um pattern matching
okay suppose you have a function like
this i like series
so we want we want to match um the first
case
um if you call a function with the
function with
both zeros as arguments and we want to
match a zero and whatever
whatever and zero and the the cash flow
case at the end
so let's create a program for that
we care about three values in this case
we care about uh the match itself and
the a and b value isn't it
a and b so what we
what we're doing here is we are just
playing
unifying um the terms that we're
interested in
so
let us start with a match
zero and zero zero and zero
so that's what we're looking for and
then let us
imagine that we're calling this function
with two arguments
that we just unify this with let's say
uh we're going to go for
zero and one and see when we get a match
so is this going to work i wonder
so oh yeah that's how i did that
can you actually see the result at the
bottom
in the back it returns an empty result
so um that means the match failed
which means that we move on to the next
clause 0 a
let's match ourselves with that and we
get a hit
so if you can see the bottom there
we see that this is the whole match
and a has been a certain value one
which seems right and b is unused
so we got a hit and this is
essentially the cheap way of doing doing
pattern matching using call logic
you just keep trying the rules until you
get a match
because at the end here we will get a
complete match
on anything we just say that a and b
equals essentially the
the arguments being passed in as you see
they are zero and one
butter matching it's horrible horribly
slow
but um yeah this is a prototype language
right
we don't really care at this point but
cool logic is fun
that's what i meant so type systems
um how are we doing for time
i think we're pretty much um out of time
but
i think we're just gonna keep going type
systems are really easy because i'm just
gonna
do some more um cool logic for you i'm
gonna
do type in friends in corelogic
because that is cool suppose you have a
function like this
the successor function simply takes an
argument
and it increments it so what can you
sell from this function
what would the type signature be
texting in returns an end or a number
so logic up
so the suk function successive function
that's what we we're interested in we
want this to be a type signature
let's introduce some more variables that
we don't care about the results so they
just have to be there
so a and b and plus a being the argument
as above b
being the result and plus being
the plus function here the plus function
is implicit is defined in the scope
so we just
say that plus is a function that returns
a and b
um so it's
the successor is also a function that
sorry that takes a and returns b
and
earning this in in the wrong order so
we see that uh plus is being called here
with a and b b being an
unknown we just have to assign them a
symbolic value to the to the one
so
we know that plus has a type signature
because it's
already defined so we assume that this
has already been inferred so we know
that this is a number
it takes a number and it returns a
number
and now we know that we are using um
we are calling suck with as input
and b as output a and b being symbols
that are supposed to
become types and we see that
we are calling plus in the same way
and we know this type signature
signature plus so this should actually
let us infer
the type signature of the successor
function
namespace not found what's that i have
to complain
oh look at that
oh wait wait wait wait sorry parenthesis
bug
this this is a communist problem don't
worry
so we see the result down here it's a
function
that takes a number and returns a number
as we can tell ourselves
so that was typing in inference done
very
very very simply in chord logic you can
get more
more fancy of course um my idea for beta
right now
is to just implement a basic uh hindi
milner time system
because i'm not very smart and hinder me
is easy to implement
so i thought i would also show you
my in liminal implementation but i see
that we are way out of time
so we're going to skip that see what's
in
on the next slide yeah so the hardest
problem in computer science and
this is usually uh the one that you you
run into at the end when your
language is is ready to be released
you have to find a name for it
you'd be surprised how difficult this is
because there are so many languages out
there that
just about every name in existence is
already taken
now some of the traditional approaches
uh
which i'm going to list for you um yeah
so um you can just go down the list
essentially until you find a good name
you can steal some person's name that's
very popular
you got haskell for one thing you got
airlang
you yeah you got lots
of famous people's names being recycled
for names and computer languages just
make sure that that you don't pick
somebody still alive that's kind of
creepy
no really i mean beta was originally
going to be called oleg
but i figured that wouldn't work out
oh like it's awesome yeah um
you could go with a general computing
computer science concept like say if
your language
uses closures then you could call it
yeah closure
um you could just take another popular
language and that's script at the end
you know fairness that wasn't brandon's
fault but i think
you could just take a letter and
increment um so
c is is kind of the successor of a
language called b
and i think we're at j now right
so you can just take that and keep going
or you could just you know name it after
your favorite pony that was what i
originally intended to do and of course
um rainbow dash is best pony so i
figured my language could be called dash
problem is of course that all names are
already taken
and dash was in fact taken by google
for their attempt to replace javascript
now apparently um there must have been
some kind of trademark um
infringement lawsuit or something
because they actually renamed it to dot
which is not best pony but there you go
at least um
i can very very well um call my language
dash
because um of the association with that
other language
so yeah we could go with
something from this list but whatever
you do
make sure you just don't name it off
yourself okay
right i think you're ready now
so
two languages that's a good one
right so i expect to see a multitude of
new toilets
bringing up after this talk so enjoy
yourselves and
thank you
so uh links um the first github link is
for the slides
it also includes both on it's what i
mean what i've been using
and the second link is for button itself
if you want to look at it
um i'm guessing we're way out of time in
contact questions yes
so thank you all for coming and enjoy
strange tape